you could easily Retreat to your home
and live a quiet private life or
insulate yourself you know with the
fancy people that you know and the
resources that you have Etc but you've
made a very different choice I don't
make the
choice it just it makes me happy to be
with people I'm a people person so I
don't say you know I should go to the
public gym I think it's cooler than
staying at home and yet during Co I
stayed at home but I was in pain I like
to train with the people I don't like to
go to football games by myself I don't
like to go for dinner by myself I don't
like to work by myself I don't like to
go to the gym and work out by myself I
just love people doing it with people
and having a good time so that that's
just me so what you see is me is totally
organic nothing is programmed or
anything like that I'm really happy that
I can live the life that I really want
to live